welcome back everybody we do have your
definitive list for the mcu as well as
sony spider-man universe it's only right
to include them because there may be a
future
where we do see uh morbius as well as
other characters from the spider-man
universe over there at sony we might see
a future with set characters over in the
616 universe aka the mcu uh it's
exciting i mean i'm going to include
them just so you guys get a more
comprehensive list uh let's get started
we have uh moon knight the disney plus
series which is going to be six episodes
uh coming march 30th 2022 we have the
morbius movie coming april 1st 2022. uh
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
may 6
and holy kale are the rumors crazy for
this one i'm excited uh next we have
she-hulk coming sometime possibly
after doctor strange and multiverse of
menace um no exact date yet but that
will be 10 episodes on disney plus
next we have thor coming july 8th 2022.
no trailer on this movie yet uh but the
hype is real for this one because we do
have natalie portman coming back not
sure if you're a fan of her but it is
definitely gonna give us a cool little
story i trust that uh taika ytt will do
a great job with this one uh next we
have miss marvel it's going to be coming
summer of this year 2022 again a disney
plus series um no word yet on how many
episodes uh then we have a spider-man
across the spider-verse part one it
looks like that one is coming october
7th 2022. i loved the first movie i know
so many people did
next we have werewolf by night which is
coming on disney plus as a disney plus
series no word on how many episodes yet
but this is october 2022
next we have black panther wakanda
forever november 11th 2022 this is the
movie that is being released sadly
without chadwick boseman i am curious
how they do handle the passing of
chadwick boseman i'm sure we've all
heard about the petition that is going
around to recast t'challa uh i don't
know what everyone's thoughts are on
that but that is a possibility
next we have the what if series it is
season two uh probably coming around
november possibly late october uh with
nine episodes
and then lastly for 2022 we have the
guardians of the galaxy coming in
december this is a disney plus special
no word yet on how long this episode
will be
but james gunn is saying himself that
this is important to the overall story
of the guardians so you do not want to
miss that one all right let's move on to
2023 we have the marvels the movie that
is coming february 17 2023
next we have a guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 coming may 5th 2023
and the last confirmed project release
date is ant-man and the wasp quantomania
this one is coming out july 28 2023 uh
i'm going to go down the list of movies
that will be released by marvel but we
do not have any confirmation on the
dates uh let's start off with a blade
which is gonna be a movie next we have
secret invasion which is gonna be a
disney plus series i am groot as well a
disney plus series uh we have spider-man
freshman year which is gonna be an
animated series coming from disney plus
also iron heart another disney plus
series x-men 97 the animated series that
is taking place right after the finale
of the original
next we have agatha house of harkness
which is a disney plus series also loki
season 2 we have armor wars disney plus
we have marvel zombies disney plus and
we have fantastic four which is gonna be
a movie no word yet obviously on when
that's gonna be released um but here are
some like honorable mentions we do have
spider woman craving the hunter deadpool
captain america for an untitled wakanda
series we have madame webb and we have
silk so that one is actually coming out
on the amazon series
again this is your most comprehensive
list uh so please us like this video if
you did subscribe if you can and i'll
see you guys tomorrow